former kickboxing champ and and
ridiculously influential social media
personality who has become a sort of
advocate for men like a I don't want to
quite compare him to Jordan Peterson but
like a sort of more fightery version of
Jordan Peterson I'm talking of course
about Andrew Tate who describes himself
as the world's most canceled man uh he
went on Patrick Bet David's podcast this
is from a day or two ago talking about
what the system will do if you stand up
against it he's referring to himself
he's clearly referring to to Trump to an
extent I think he's referring to you
know the broader all of us
I hammered the point home and I made it
very clear that they had the intention
of trying to put me in jail I said
there's three lives they try and cancel
you and slander you and destroy your
name they don't just want you to
disappear from the internet they want to
disappear from the internet in a cloud
of Shame they have to shame you which is
why they chose the crimes they did for
me and it's why they usually choose the
crimes they choose because it's heinous
they want to shame you and they want you
to Disappear With Your Head facing the
ground and never pop up again obviously
they attempted to cancel me I became
more famous than ever before I even said
to you on your podcast and I said on
another podcast I said I think they made
a mistake I think when you have power
and you overuse it you what happens is a
rebellion that's how a revolution starts
when you have power you have to be very
very careful with how you use that power
the second you overuse it there's a
revolution like and we're in Romania so
they know all about that that's exactly
what happens and I I said at the time I
think I was a mistake I think they made
a big mistake canceling me the way they
did
and then the second time the second life
which I described as they try and put
you in jail for no reason here we are in
the current scenario I knew it was going
to happen and the third one is they put
a bullet in your head so we're gonna
have to see how the second life plays
out and yeah I mean when this is all
over and I win the court case I get the
not guilty I won't be smiling I'll be
walking out the courtroom with my head
on this level
that's the kind of life I'm living now
I'm gonna be thinking oh okay so their
second attempt failed now what like do I
want to fly private anymore do I want to
go to that place anymore you start to
think about these things like do I want
to do these things law billionaires
dying in plane crashes is strange so
it's scary regardless of how it plays
out and I guess you just have to go with
the punches and and see where it lands
and God has a plan for for me and for
all of us and we're just going to see
how it ends up okay so just to give you
a little context on that I don't want to
get into all of the charges related to
uh Andrew Tate but they shot that this
is two or three days ago that is in
Romania he was in jail in Romania on
charges that I think they never fully
released actually for six months in jail
now he's on house arrest in Romania so
Patrick Bet David flew to Romania for
this interview the point is that that
Andrew Tate who's fighting the system
telling people to believe in themselves
and not believe the nonsense and believe
in biological reality and everything
else he's showing you this is what they
will do to you I am now stuck in Romania
in house arrest and I will eventually
win the court case but what will they do
to me after and I think there's an
obvious parallel to some extent with
what's going on here with Donald Trump